[Music]
it's January and chances are you've made
some kind of resolution to get in shape
or be healthier I know I have now I'm
not a big fan of going to the gym or
running or getting off the couch unless
it's absolutely necessary but I am a fan
of the gamification of exercise while
games like arms just dance and one two
switch have elements of physicality to
them and even calorie counters in the
case of Just Dance fitness boxing is
Nintendo's first dedicated exa gaming
release on switch and I was keen to
check it out having spent money on
actual boxing gloves I have never used I
was wary of dropping more dollars on the
idea of boxing and at $50 fitness boxing
is a little steep Nintendo and developer
Imagineer have released a free demo
fitness boxing which gives you an idea
of what to expect but the full version
features a number of really nice touches
like plugging in your own stats
customized workouts and changing
trainers quite apart from letting you
play for more than three daily workouts
and ten free sessions which the trial
version is limited to at a basic level
you'll be holding a joy con in each fist
and executing various punches in time
with a handful of instrumental versions
of top 40 songs the most interesting
feature is a customizable daily workout
where you can elect what areas to work
on your fitness goals and how long to
make each session I got about halfway
through my first daily workout before
severely regretting selecting 35 minute
sessions but the game had promised me
that this particular mashup of jabs
uppercuts and hooks would burn two
hundred and thirty-odd calories so I
reluctantly powered through I'm not
entirely sure where this number comes
from but I was absolutely working up a
sweat during the session and my arms
were sore for days afterwards though we
can't exactly confirm if that's just
down to my complete lack of fitness
learning to properly wind up punches so
you can deliver them in strings that
perfectly timed hits is satisfying and
the encouragement and guidance you
receive from your personal digital
trainer helps a lot
all right that's good aside from that
the game has a couple of two-player
modes if you can get a mate to bring
their joy cones over and loads of
different moves that make up each of the
free workout and daily sessions so the
segments are noticeably different every
time and get more complex as you go that
said I did experience some
inconsistencies with the motion control
mechanics the joy cones are great at
picking up movement but they don't
necessarily seem to mind which movement
it wasn't immediately obvious if I was
indeed miss timing punches or if the
wrong movement was being detected as
sometimes my wind-up for a punch would
register as the execution meaning my
timing would register as off coupled
with a lack of explanations of technique
and form for each punch this led to some
frustrating detection issues it also
seemed easier to judge punch timing by
the visual aids on screen and the
instructors count instead of the music
which was a bit of a shame but
ultimately you're still getting a
workout whether the system registers it
or not now I'm not one of those high on
the endorphins of fitness kinds of
people so the only way I can get through
it is to distract myself from the
crappiness of painful exercise given the
easy listening pop tracks weren't
distracting me enough from the torturous
act of working out nor were they
particularly helpful for timing I opted
to change up my tactics you have the
option to turn down the volume of the
trainer sound effects for background
music so I switched off the music in
favor of the most enjoyable distracting
thing I can imagine
back-to-back segments of last week
tonight with John Oliver you have six
intimidatingly fit trainers to choose
from who all have limited programmed
voice lines so get ready to hear alright
that's good so many times it'll work its
way into your dreams despite the muddly
robotic voices of most of the trainer's
being reminded to breathe keep your form
lift your hands and told when to deal a
blow is really helpful I chose the
trainer with an Australian accent as she
sounded the most natural to me but you
can swap between them as you go alright
let's get down to it you can also unlock
in your clothing items for each trainer
as well as extra songs by completing
workouts which is a smart way of making
workouts feel worth it when you reach
the end personally I usually treat
- a post-workout beer but this is
probably healthier while it won't
explicitly train you on proper form and
technique fitness boxing will definitely
help you work up a sweat if you put the
time in
holding the joy concers natural and easy
and having a daily reason to come back
is clever piecemeal motivation as is the
option to pile on extra practice
sessions if you're feeling particularly
workout inclined I've been playing
fitness boxing for just over a week and
it feels like just the right amount of
balance of gamification reward and
workout without having to leave the
couch for too long while I'm still
holding out the switch fit this one is a
good buy if you're already into the idea
of boxer size and it's worth keeping an
eye out for a sale if you're interested
eyes games but put off by the current
price tag
[Music]